nous sommes de nouveau à l'opéra royal
du château de versailles toujours en
compagnie de jean paul doucet qui a été
son premier directeur technique alors là
nous sommes sur cette scène où vous nous
aviez parlé et qui a été la première
chose qui vous a étonné et bailly en
arrivant ici parce que là les dimensions
de la scène du palais garnier 1
alors on a parlé dans première fois de
ce qui s'était passé quand vous êtes
arrivé c'était une salle où il y avait
des spectacles n'hésitez pas une salle
qui n'était faite que pour des
spectacles le spectacle était régulier
mais c'était une salle de musée la barre
donc avec un nombre incalculable de
visiteurs qui étaient tous accompagnés
d'un conférencier et ce sur ajoutez à
cela la programmation du centre de
musique baroque qui se résumait à
quelques concerts est rarement un
spectacle monté en scène mais surtout
l'opéra royal était à la disposition de
la présidence de la république à tout
moment qu'ils pouvaient le
réquisitionner pour les besoins de la
politique c'est ainsi que françois
mitterrand a reçu ici même dès 37 chefs
d'état et de gouvernement en somme et
1989 4,8 en 1989 et ça a été mon baptême
du feu donc mon premier spectacle ça va
recevoir 37 chefs d'état mais ça s'est
passé comment eh bien ça s'est passé que
nous avions reçu la note de service si
josi et il fallait c'était donc
quelqu'un que je connaissais bien pour
l'avoir connu le faire at paris c'était
patrick dupont oui qui était pressenti
s'est donné un spectacle
deux nuls et puis comme on se
connaissait bien et bien on va faire des
sexes reste c'est un des crises qu'elle
allait faire et puis d'un coup il
je vis mais ouais l'orchestré il
m'arrive en mai a pas besoin soit la
danse nous on a une bande ça suffit je
vis non je pense que ça ne suffit pas il
y a quand même des personnes de qualité
de cette assistance et on ne peut pas au
nom de la france
ce produit est vendu quelque chose comme
ça et alors c'est là où je reçois un
appel de l'elysée en me disant vous avez
carte blanche pour réquisitionner lors
qu'être de votre choix
et à l'époque j'appelle donc celui qui
est encore un ami georges françois
hirsch pour lui demander son avis il me
répond qu'est ce que tu veux mais tu ne
prends pas leur caisse de l'opéra de
paris
ça veut ce supposé annuler un spectacle
et flamands ce qui a été extraordinaire
c est l orchestre la version symphonique
de la garde républicaine
donc c'était il faut imaginer quand même
la marseillaise de berlioz qui résonnait
dans une fosse d'orchestre 1 à
l'occasion de l'ouverture du spectacle
enchaînant donc toutes les pièces du
ballet pour une soirée et on re
découvraient ce qu'étaient les grandes
fêtes de l'ancien régime puisque en fait
c'est un opéra royal voilà alors ça
c'est très important ce que vous dites
parce qu'au fond il ya un lien fort un
lien toujours très étroit entre cette
salle il ya eu en tout cas peut-être que
ça change aujourd'hui vécu un lien entre
cette salle et le pouvoir vous faut
c'est ça et alors il ya par exemple il
ya une grille qu'on voit là bas vous
avez vous raconter ce que ce que cette
grille qui est derrière nous sous
l'ancien régime
le roi est roi de droit divin
ce qui veut dire qu'en toutes
circonstances surtout me priver il
demeure roi de france et dans la grande
tradition française
le roi lorsqu'il est en représentation
n'est pas au même endroit que lorsqu'il
est temps à son ordi
en d'autres termes si vous allez à la
chapelle vous verrez la tribune royale
c'est là où le roi tous les matins prend
place pour entendre la messe ordinaire
lorsqu'il est en grande cérémonie six
fois par an il descend donc en bas dans
la nef et il prend place dans le choeur
sous un dais ou hilarants d'évêques et
c'est là où il distribue par exemple la
très prisée décoration l'ordre de du
saint-esprit ce qui ce qui a été
remplacé plus tard par la lyre d'honneur
et donc c'est là dans une grande
cérémonie à l'avoine côte où le roi
officie si j'ose dire et bien à l'opéra
royal le lieu laïque et bien c'est
pareil lorsque le roi et sa son
ordinaire il prend place dans les loges
grillé qui sont d'ici un an mais pour le
roy on enlève les grilles
bien sûr mais lorsqu'elle a donc veillé
avec les varois n'est pas là ou alors ce
que faisait quelques fois louis 15
il vient incognito à partir assister au
spectacle et dans ce cas là il s'assied
ou à la haye sinon lorsqu'il dans grande
cérémonie c'est tout l'amphithéâtre qui
à la loge royale
le roi est assis sur un fauteuil au
milieu et ensuite de part et d'autre la
famille royale et un arrière-plan
les gardes suisses les gardes du corps
mais alors votre départ quand gabriel
construit la salle au départ il y avait
l'idée de faire une loge non alors voilà
ça c'est le
vrai la vraie rupture avec le goût
étrange et quand vous allez au san carlo
de naples vous allez dans tous les
adhérents des loges vous avez une grande
loge triomphal au beau milieu de la cèze
que l'on devine parce que c'était le
projet initial si vous regardez l'ex
être qu'ils se trouvent dans laxe de la
salle donc autres monnaies dans cette
loi c'est le cul tour que nous voyons où
tout à fait la demie coupole eh bien
vous marquerez qu' il y avait une
colonne qui là qu'il a des gros de part
et d'autre mais c est vous surbaissé la
loge du roi et vous construisez un débat
grand balcon en avant corps et bien
c'était la loge du roi et ça n'a pas été
possible
c'était ce qui était prévu au début
c'était ce qui était bleu d'evry à la
fin et c'est ce qui a été modifié en
cours de chantier et regarder comment
gabriel a réussi à récupérer un
événement dont il a dû vraiment se
désole c'est à dire que l'idée comme ça
c'est que le roi est partout chez lui
quoi il n'est pas retouché lui 11e
pâteuse n'y a pas de raison de me faire
loge spécial puisqu'il peut s'installer
où il veut alors évidemment pas de la
même façon selon que ce soit cérémonie
officielle qu'on ait aujourd'hui où
qu'ils soient lents privée parfois il
est chez lui donc il n'y a pas de besoin
d'avoir un lieu attribuée non ah c'est
ça non et puis surtout encore une fois
cette notion l'ordinaire et
l'extraordinaire bien et comme cet opéra
royal a été construit pour
l'extraordinaire c'est à dire pour des
besoins politiques et bien
très souvent il a servi lorsque le roi
était en bas mais il n'empêche que on
donnait aussi des spectacles d'entre
deux où là le roi et et en os et surtout
la famille royale mais tous complique
parce que la famille royale
c'était qui s'était donc à un moment
donné c'était aussi les filles de louis
qu'un et les filles de louis 15 fille de
roi exigeait d'être au plus proche
possible de leur père et elles ont exigé
et obtenu d'installer une l'âge au beau
milieu de la porte d'entrée d'efforts
d'accès à à l'amphitéa mais c'est quand
même frappe
enfin que ce lieu c'est versailles c'est
de ce lieu est toujours été lié quand
même au pouvoir
est-ce que ça va toujours aujourd'hui
est ce qui a encore quand françois
hollande ou nicolas sarkozy est ce qui a
encore des opéras qui se donne ici au
nom de la république alors la dernière
fois qu'il a été utilisé pour la
réception de président chinois
un cancer a eu lieu ici même donc
c'était un dernier il ya deux ans et qui
a été donnée ici dans un concert qui
fait plaisir à tout le monde la
programmation chinoise et française
entre mer et donc ça reste quand même
lieu ou voilà où on montre qui quand
même un lieu de pouvoir
on a parlé de l'époque vous êtes arrivé
ici
évidemment il ya eu quand même il ya un
avant et un après c'est pour rire c'est
2009 c'est là c'est la rénovation totale
de l'aube en 2009 nous réussissons le
tour de force à abattre ce mur coupe feu
il ya déchaîné la colère de strehler et
la brune jeu c'est quelquefois rester
calmes mais sachez simplement que tous
les ministres de la culture qu'elles
sont venues visiter versailles sont tous
descendus dans les dessous où j'avais
préparé une massette et ils ont tous
donné symboliquement un coup de marteau
pour casser le mur coupe feu
oui et c'est ce qui a été achevé en 2009
alors qu'ils sont là et bien tout ce qui
succède à jacques lang donc il ya eu
celui que je connais encore c'est
jacques toubon mais qu'est-ce qu'il ya
d'autres valeurs jean jacques aillagon
qui était le sien et qui était le patron
voilà donc donc ça ça a été ça a été
essentielle évidemment pour pour
retrouver tout ce que pouvait donner
l'opéra la salle aussi a été refaite
non non non pas de la salle a été
magnifiquement restauré en 1957 aller
vite entre tel quel et c'est encore
convenable mais c'était la scène qui
faisait défaut
alors il faut dire une chose parce que
on voit beaucoup d'or
dans cette salle mais c'est du bois tout
et en beauté trop mal au grand désespoir
de gabriel qui aurait bien aimé tel
caserte faire une belle salle en marbre
ah oui mais quand la décision royale est
prise d'avancer la date du mariage au 16
mai 1770 cette décision est prise en 65
c'est à dire qu'il reste très peu de
temps et vous savez ce que c'est c'est
qu'encore comme aujourd'hui quand on
décide quelque chose
le temps quand il pourrait soumettre les
projets que les modifie quand les
ratifie et tout ça a été achevée en 22
mois on travaille jour et nuit pour
rétablir tout ce qu'on voit aujourd'hui
ce corps
alors on va pas parler de l'ensemble de
la programmation parce que on peut
renvoyer les gens sur le sur le site de
versailles spectacles qui est très bien
fait sur laquelle on voit toute la
programmation
il ya quand même veiller encore quand
même je crois cecilia bartoli qui va
venir
patricia petibon qu'il ya comme des
choses extraordinaires mais tout ça qui
illustre une parfaite saison théâtrale
ce dont moi même j'ai toujours été
frustré jusqu'en 2009 mais d'ailleurs
moi j'essaie des formes au soir la
direction technique du théâtre mais je
suis toujours présent parce qu'elle aime
complicité qui s'installe c'est à dire
voir réaliser un rêve c'est ce que c'est
ce dont vous avez rêvé ab de toute ma
vie c'est à dire que vos vingt ans pour
démolir un mur qui va permettre de
donner une vraie saison et c'est donc ce
qui se passe en ce moment dont vous avez
de l'opéra du ballet et des concerts des
concerts et des bourses
et encore une fois on va sur le site de
versailles spectacles pour les
spectacles qui auront lieu cette année
merci infiniment alors vous allez rester
quand même un petit peu ici un pour
continuer à donner vos conseils
oui parce que d'abord les opérateurs
demeurent encore à la maison mais c'est
plus à titre de d'études et notamment je
suis sollicité à fontainebleau
il existe aussi un théâtre et à
compiègne où il existe encore un terreau
de 18 secondes et puis aussi beaucoup en
france dans d'autres cités châtellerault
et puis j'ai travaillé puis aix les
bains et puis tous les petits théâtres
privés qui subsistent encore en france
et surtout à l'étranger mais continue
encore longtemps l'opéra royal de
versailles
merci beaucoup son prix